the government's insisting that it is
acting within international law after
publishing legislation to override parts
of the brexit deal the foreign secretary
says the uk is still open to
negotiations with the european union
despite making moves to ignore the
northern ireland protocol
we're very clear that we're acting in
line with the law we'll be publishing
our legal statement later today what is
vitally important
is that we do resolve this situation in
northern ireland that is causing real
problems we haven't seen the executive
operating since february we need to get
power sharing re-established we know how
hard one the belfast good friday
agreement was and that is why the
government has to act
that is why we are introducing this
legislation now of course we remain open
to negotiations with the eu and i would
rather achieve this through a negotiated
settlement the fact is the eu
the eu have refused to change the
protocol which is causing these problems
on trade on tax
and more broadly in northern ireland
well the move has been welcomed by the
democratic unionists but shin fein says
it's a clear violation of the law
i believe that uh finally we are now
seeing the kind of
action that is required
uh to begin the process of removing the
barriers for trade within the united
kingdom
to restoring northern ireland's place
within the uk internal market as the
bill progresses we will consider what
steps we can take along with others to
build
progress to make progress in northern
ireland i want these institutions up and
running but i'm also clear
we need to be sure that this legislation
is going forward
today's action by boris johnson in
westminster is absolutely reckless it's
disgraceful
it does nothing to serve the interests
of the people here it flies in the face
of an international agreement which he
himself negotiated it is unclear breach
of international law
and it is you know the reality is here
that the protocol is working the
majority of businesses have been out and
be very vocal on that 80 percent of
businesses would say the protocol is
working it's actually affording them
great opportunities it's creating jobs
and yet and all we have boris johnson
again delivering on
the commitment that he made to breach
international law i don't think that's a
good look on anybody
michelle o'neill there we've got
correspondence in westminster belfast
and brussels let's uh go first to
westminster and rob powell so
clearly rob a controversial
move by the government just remind us
why they claim this is necessary
well they say it's necessary because
they think there are problems that are
being caused in northern ireland by the
northern ireland protocol that means
that the uk needs to take action on its
own to amend the protocol and they're
going to do that through a bill that's
just been published this is it the
northern ireland protocol bill
and it is 20 pages long and if you just
read basically the first main chunk of
it that has the overview of the main
provisions you get a sense of what it's
designed to do it said this act provides
that certain specified provisions of the
northern ireland protocol does not have
effect in the united kingdom and it
gives ministers of the crown powers to
make new law in connection with the
northern ireland protocol so really as
suspected for a long time a bill that
will be probably anyway passed through
the commons and the lords that will give
ministers here in westminster power to
uh rewrite to make new law in regards to
the northern ireland protocol to
disapply parts of the northern ireland
protocol
as well
in terms of specifically what that will
be well from the briefings we've been
having with the government today they
say that it's essentially focused on
four main parts the first is creating
this green and red channel system for
products coming into northern ireland so
that
goods that come through the green
channel which are not at risk not likely
to be moved on to the eu don't have to
have so much paperwork and so many
checks whilst the red goods still would
have full checks the second is about
regulation about standards and about
allowing goods into northern ireland
making them saying that they can either
abide by the eu regime or the uk regime
so a dual regime essentially um in in
northern ireland the third is about the
application of vat and state aid rules
and the fourth is about governance
essentially about what role european
courts have in
arbitrating disputes in northern ireland
the uk wants there to be an independent
arbitration process which can just have
reference to european court so european
courts wouldn't get the final say on
disputes um in northern ireland
in terms of the legal position in all of
this um the government has also
published online a statement of what
they say is their legal underpinning for
their um justification that this does
not in their view breach international
law and they are relying on something
called the doctrine of necessity where
essentially they say
it provides a clear basis and i'm
reading to you from their justification
here on online a clear basis in
international law to justify the
non-performance of international
obligations under certain exceptional
and limited circumstances now the
exceptional limited circumstances that
they are relying on that they are
talking about is
what they see as the political the
social impact that the northern ireland
protocol is having on life in northern
ireland so essentially they believe the
situation being caused by the protocol
in northern ireland is so severe that it
crosses the threshold and gives them
grounds to disapply parts of the brexit
deal parts of the northern ireland
protocol that boris johnson signed some
two and a half years ago now i think
what we will see over the coming hours
days and probably weeks are
international law experts that have a
much much much more um uh well-versed in
this than i could ever be uh unpick this
bill unpick the legalese in this bill um
and come to their own decision about
whether um they think this does indeed
breach international law the
government's position at the moment
though is that they don't believe it
does but of course there have been
disputes over which top government
lawyers have had their say over this and
accusations essentially of the
government shopping around for legal
advice that fits their political aim so
i think we will see that row over the
legal grounding for this and play out in
the coming days but the end result of
what's happened in the last hour is that
this 20-page bill the northern ireland
protocol bill has been introduced into
the house of commons it's had its first
reading a relatively quick procedural uh
process that goes on in the commons it
will be back in a couple of weeks time
probably for its second reading it's at
that point we will get a lot more anger
from the green benches and potentially a
rebellion from conservative mps as well
okay rob thanks very much let's go to uh
belfast and uh stephen murphy and we
heard at the top of the programme uh
there stephen uh
welcomed by the unionists and condemned
by sinn fein
doctrine of necessity as rob uh was
explaining there it doesn't really cut
much mustard here with the nationalist
community the nationalist parties at
storm and certainly didn't cut any
mustard with michelle o'neill i directly
asked her is what boris johnson's doing
today
illegal and she said yes she said
definitively yes it breaches
international law breaches uh the brexit
withdrawal agreement and the protocol
obviously contained uh within uh she is
furious she called it reckless and she
called it a dangerous move that serves
nobody it doesn't serve the people here
in northern ireland she said and it
doesn't serve the businesses either what
champagne can actually do about it
though is another question obviously
they're not represented in westminster
she has urged the british government and
the european commission to try to bang
their heads again and step up and
ratchet up negotiations this time she
said in good faith she was obviously
implying that the british government was
a bad faith negotiating partner up until
this point and then of course it was sir
jeffrey donaldson the leader of the
dep's turn to face the media and we got
a completely different reaction he
warmly welcomed this uh legislation just
to remind you the dup is uh boycotting
uh the assembly here at storm and that's
why we don't have an executive a power
sharing government here they say they
won't go back in until the protocol
issue is tackled until it's sorted so
the big question obviously is does this
do that he won't be drawn yet they have
seven individual tests they said they're
going to apply obviously he hasn't seen
the um the small print of this
legislation either so the dup won't be
drawn yet on whether this is enough to
restore power sharing which of course is
something that liz trust referred to
there and boris johnson has referred to
there they would love to see that uh be
a uh outcome of this legislation but we
don't know yet whether the dep will play
ball okay stephen thanks very much and
uh finally to brussels and adam parsons
and so adam how will the eu
uh react to this do you think
we have already had the first uh
reactions and fair to say that the eu is
going on exactly the terms
that we uh predicted they are furious
they have said that they will not
renegotiate the northern ireland
protocol i've already had messages from
diplomats uh who say that they are being
quote unquote played again
by boris johnson's government that is
the message that's been sent to me
another one saying to me that when boris
johnson needed a deal we helped to get
him one across the line one that he
signed
and now that it suits him he's trying to
bring it down again there is a great
deal of cynicism here but there is
already reaction from mauro sefkovic the
eu's chief negotiator talking about this
uh saying that the northern ireland
protocol is the only method that you by
which you can balance the requirements
of the good friday agreement and the
requirements of the eu's single market i
think we can listen now to just a little
bit of mr sefekovich talking also about
in his mind the impossibility of
renegotiating the protocol
renegotiating of the protocol is
unrealistic
no workable alternative solution has
been found to this delicate
long-negotiated
balance any renegotiations would simply
bring further legal uncertainty for the
people and businesses in northern
ireland
for these reasons the european union
will not renegotiate the protocol
this position uh we're in this curious
position whereby both sides are in
effect making the same argument in the
uk and uh across the eu basis saying
they are the ones protecting the good
friday agreement both sides insisting
that they are open uh to negotiation and
it is the others who are being dogmatic
of course one profound difference is the
eu says you cannot bring down this
protocol the uk is saying it you need to
and one other thing is i said to you a
little earlier that i thought it was
very likely that the legal proceedings
would start soon against the uk
i think that is ever more likely i think
that process will begin in the next 48
hours or so three things may happen one
is that a former process that was frozen
will be unfrozen secondly
more proceedings will be started that is
in the terms of the trade agreement and
thirdly by the way there is this
prospect uh that if this becomes ever
more rancorous that there could be
tariff
in the start of a trade war and and
there is a thought that terrorists could
be introduced on industries who are
based in the constituencies of
high-profile mps problem is i'm told
that they've looked at places like
uxbridge and norfolk and not found many
industries that actually
could be heard
by eu terrace but that is the level of
negotiation we've got to make no mistake
this is turning into a very very bitter
argument yeah absolutely adam thanks
very much adam parsons there in
brussels stephen murphy and rob powell
thank you all